[Applaudissements]
bonsoir tout le monde
philippe comment vous appelez-vous si on
est parti comme ça on va y passer la
nuit
et comme disent les québécois on n'est
pas rendu mais je vais quand même vous
présenter mes deux copains
mes deux copains en l'occurrence sont le
singe beagle et le robot non sapiens
hector salut charles comment vas tu
qu'est ce qui m'arrive je m'adresse à
charles darwin qui est mort le 19 avril
1882 si je m'adresse à lui
ici je le dérange dans son repos
séculaire dans l'abbaye de westminster
c'est tout simplement parce que je pense
que cette théorie sur l'évolution de
l'espèce elle bat de l aile vous
connaissez la vie de charles darwin
c'est l'exemple vivant je pense que
l'adjectif n'est pas heureux c'est
l'exemple tout court d'un scientifique
avec un esprit excessivement ouvert et
transversale il commence des études de
médecine à l'université d'edimbourg et
il échouera au grand dam de ses parents
qui se sont probablement non dits oufti
que va-t-on faire avec ce gamin il va
ensuite étudié la théologie à
l'université de cambridge
et pour finir il sera engagé comme
volontaire naturaliste et géologue sur
un navire de guerre de la flotte
anglaise transformé en navire
scientifique un siècle avant la calypso
du commandant cousteau le beagle et
c'est pour ça que j'ai appelé mon copain
le singe
le beacon et c'est là qu'en tant que
scientifique y collectionnera des
ossements fossiles vous et moi je suis
absolument certain que pendant ces beau
voyage sur le beagle
nous aurions collectionner tout à fait
autre chose et en observant ces
ossements fossiles il va enfin évoqué la
théorie sur l'évolution de l'espèce en
alors il sera également frappé par la
ressemblance entre nous et nos amis les
singes mais je pense qu'il faut pas être
un savant scientifiques comme darwin
pour observer cette ressemblance
ma maman m'a toujours dit que j'avais
les bras aussi long qu'un chimpanzé et
je vous rassure
ma mère n'était pas une scientifique du
tout c'était une littéraire pur jus mais
ce qui va rassurer darwin aujourd'hui je
pense c'est que les scientifiques ont pu
démontrer que les éléments de base les
petits légaux qui constitue notre adn
notre code génétique sont excessivement
ressemblant entre nous et les grands
singes et la différence ne se joue que
sur 1,25 pour cent
et pourtant je m'attaque à la théorie de
darwin
je m'attaque à cette théorie tout
simplement parce que je pense qu'elle
est basée sur la sélection naturelle est
ce que je remets en question aujourd'hui
c'est l'adjectif naturel pour la
première fois à houston en février 2017
on a évoqué que le transit manis mme
serait le prochain pas de l'évolution de
la race humaine
mais quelles sont les techniques quels
sont les sciences qui permettent de
tenir des propos qui certainement à
l'époque de darwin peuvent être
considérés comme hérétiques
mais que nous considérons probablement
aussi comme hérétique
je vais en illustrer 3 les exosquelettes
la modification du code génétique et la
possibilité de faire la fusion entre le
cerveau humain et l'ordinateur
cela vous effraye cela m'effraie tout
autant parce que bien entendu ces
développements technologiques ont pour
but d'améliorer l'espèce humaine
d'alléger les souffrances des hommes
mais en même temps elles vont de pair
avec une multitude de dérive
commençons donc par du sauveteur
commençons par les exosquelettes vous
connaissez tous ses appendices développé
pour l'armée américaine qui sont des
appendices motorisés dont on peut doter
les soldats qui leur permettent d'aller
plus loin d'aller plus vite de sauter
plus haut de porter des charges plus
importantes
ceci leur confère bien entendu un
avantage stratégique mais en même temps
les dérives sont multiples et certaines
de ces dérives peuvent être taxés de
ludique ou de futile tels que ces
énormes araignées motorisés robotisée
articulé dans lequel on installe au
centre de l'araignée un humain et qui
vont concourir
un petit peu de la manière d'une course
automobile
mais là où ça devient moins futiles et
moins ludique c'est quand je faisais ce
de chez amazon déclare avoir construit
un robot bipède qui fait 1,5 tonne et 5
mètres de haut
ça ne vous rappelle rien les robots
bipèdes avatar imaginer en effet qu on
dote ce robot bipède avec des armes
destructrices et on peut imaginer
automatiquement les dégâts que cela
ferait si ces armes là était dans les
mains mal intentionnées de terroristes
et là où ça devient beaucoup moins
ludique c'est quand des états souverains
qui sont passés maîtres dans l'art de la
robotisation se lancent le défi en août
2017 d'un combat à mort entre robots
bipèdes non habitée c'est le japon et
les etats unis ils viennent d'être
rejoints par un troisième état souverain
la chine
mais si vous ou moi nous étions cloué
dans une chaise roulante après un
accident de voiture un accident de moto
ou comme cette jeune femme qui revenait
du ski à aspen dans le colorado
nous aurions été ravis de pouvoir
bénéficier d'un de ces exosquelette
développé par l'armée qui lui a permis
enfin de se lever de sa chaise roulante
et de marché aussi vous ou moi nous
étions le papa ou la maman de cette
adorable petit garçon royal qui est née
avec un bras gauche en moins nous
supporterions totalement l'initiative
qui a été pris par son papa de recherche
de fonds sur indy gogo afin de financer
le brevet de commercialiser son
invention qui n'est rien d'autre qu'une
prothèse articulé qui s'adaptera à la
croissance de l'enfant
et certaines de ces prothèses sont
intelligentes elles sont capables de
capter la densité de l'objet de
l'envoyer au cerveau qui lui effectué un
rétro contrôle sur la pression exercée
par la prothèse ça c'est du soft
permettait maintenant qu'on passe aux
ardeurs en matière d ardeur je voudrais
vous parler de la capacité que nous
avons de jouer avec le code génétique
je vous rassure tout de suite en matière
de code génétique deux aspects à
discuter d'abord le clonage
le clonage soyez rassurés dolly et ses
brebis et ses congénères se portent
super bien et quand je dis que nous
sommes capables de modifier avec une
précision diabolique
voire même chirurgicale le code
génétique j'évoque surtout deux pays en
l'occurrence la corée du sud et la chine
ils ont même été évoqué la possibilité
de cloner nos grands cousins les singes
et pourquoi pas le mammouth laineux et
l'homme de neandertal pendant qu'on y
est le simple fait d'évoquer cette
possibilité scientifiques donnent des
frissons dans le dos mais à nouveau si
vous aviez vécu pendant 15 ans avec un
compagnon fidèle votre chien qui vient
de disparaître
vous seriez excessivement ravi et si
vous êtes fortune et bien entendu de
demander à une équipe de corée du sud 2
vous le cloner et si vous vous étiez le
papa ou la maman de ce bambin qui est
touché par une semie incurable au stade
terminal
je suis absolument certain que comme
parent responsable
vous auriez accepté de le traiter avec
des cellules immunes au compétentes
provenant d'un donneur non compatibles
mais préalablement modifiées
génétiquement afin qu'il n'y ait pas de
rejet et s'ils vous moi ou d'autres
personnes dans cette salle comptait
parmi les membres de sa famille
quelqu'un qui souffre d'une de ces
maladies génétiquement déterminer qu'on
appelle pudiquement des maladies
orphelines pour lesquelles il n'y a
aucune option thérapeutique actuelle
nous serions
totalement d'accord avec la proposition
qui a été faite par l'académie des
sciences aux états unis et l'académie de
médecine qui prône pour que la
manipulation génétique rentrer dans les
moeurs et soit utilisé dans le contexte
d'essais cliniques contrôlés et ce sera
le cas en 2017 pour l'anémié falciforme
la maladie de duchenne qui provoque une
atrophie de vos muscles et qui est
mortelle
la rétinite pigmentaire qui provoque la
cécité et là je sens mon cher d'arles
darwin que tu est effrayée et tu seras
paniquer à l'évocation de la troisième
technologies je citais tout à l'heure
une troisième technologie qui consiste à
évoquer la possibilité de fusionner le
cerveau humain avec un ordinateur
balivernes sottise de savant fou tu
parles charles
ricour soit elle qui est un des gourous
du transhumanisme un des pontes de la
silicon valley annoncé que cette
prouesse technologique devrait être à
notre disposition d'ici 2030
il est suivi par une ribambelle
d'adapter d'icare qui en essayant de
s'approcher du soleil risque bien de se
brûler les ailes
et parmi eux on retrouve elon musk et
l'on est ce qu est en effet loin d'être
un transit manistes c'est un pragmatique
cas les pieds bien sur terre et bientôt
sur mars
c'est aussi le patron de space x thèse
la rai peu loupé boeing company et le
losc a crié en grand secret en 2016
sa société ne râle inc il vient de
l'annoncer publiquement ces sociétés a
comme unique but de réaliser cette
prouesse technologique
il est suivi par mark zuckerberg chez
facebook qui a mis en ordre de marche
ses ingénieurs ses cherche chercheurs
ces informaticiens du fameux bâtiment où
huit de chez facebook bâtiment dans
lequel on développe des technologies
innovantes
mais sur quoi se basent style pour être
aussi fasciné par cette possibilité
il se base sur les travaux du darpa
est ce que vous connaissez le darpa le
dard passé les différences avance agency
de l'armée américaine ces gens là sont
des scientifiques fous il développe
plusieurs projets dont certains d'entre
eux sont tout simplement terrifiant 1 et
ses projets c'est le rio ave nautiques
entre contrôle électronique des
solutions of memories il utilise un
animal de laboratoire en l'occurrence le
rat et avec une stimulation électronique
ils sont parvenus à effacer des pans
entiers de la mémoire du rat les
résultats sont tellement probant
aujourd'hui que le darpa évoque très
sérieusement la possibilité de les
extrapoler chez l'homme ça ne vous
rappelle rien
man in black le deuxième projet est
encore plus effrayant c'est le
développement de nanou beau ne vont
engineering systems design ce sont des
micropuces qu'on peut implanter dans le
cerveau et qui permettent la connexion
directe entre le cerveau et l'ordinateur
on rentre dans le concept de la matrice
mais si vous ou moi nous étions paralysé
depuis de nombreuses années dans un lit
totalement cloud et nous irions avec
énormément d'attention les résultats des
travaux scientifiques qui ont été
publiées sur un modèle animal y est le
macaque au laboratoire chez qui ces
scientifiques ont d'abord provoqué une
lésion transverse de la moelle épinière
rendant le macaque paralysée du train
arrière
ils ont implanté une interface neuro
prosthetic qui permet de capter le
signal qui donne l'ordre de marche de
l'envoyer par un système sans fil vers
un capteur qui lui se trouve 10 stalmans
de la lésion médullaire et qui permet de
marcher aux macaques et avouez que ça
fait quand même pas mal de siècle on
nous rabat les oreilles avec lève toi et
marche
et là mon cher darwin je sens que tu es
dans claque que théo frétille et je suis
absolument certain que les courants
d'air de l'abbaye de westminster n'y
sont absolument pour rien vous et moi
nous sommes conscients que ces
technologies sont développées dans le
but de l'amélioration
du genre humain pour résoudre des
problèmes de souffrance humaine mais
chacune de ces technologies comporte un
nombre innombrable de dérive car science
sans conscience comme disait rabelais
n'est que ruine de l'âme
et c'est pour ça que par mes petite
causerie mes petites interventions
j'essaye de sensibiliser mécontents mes
compatriotes terrien mais comme les
trois singes à six oreilles bouche et
paupières closes
il persiste dans le déni du vrai message
de ma prose mais je continuerai charles
car je suis intimement convaincu que si
la poésie peut rejoindre la science le
genre humain
dans un ultime sursaut de sagesse saura
utiliser ces techniques et ses
innovations dans l'ultime but
d'améliorer la condition humaine sur
terre et la qualité de vie avec un grand
v sur ce charles
je te salue je te dis à bientôt mais si
j'ai le choix le plus tard possible
quant à toi hector arrête de ricaner
l'ère des robots sans conscience n'est
pas encore venu bonne soirée
[Applaudissements]